America's you know is halfway through
the federal government's 15 days of
recommended social distancing our dr.
David agus is in Los Angeles he's also
social distancing he's at his home in
Los Angeles let's start with the
president David because he appears to be
at odds with the health experts about
about how long this should go on if it
comes to that who wins in this dispute
and what is the risk there I think
everybody thinks that it needs to be a
four to six week minimum of the what we
call the social distancing now remember
each person in the Chinese data can
actually spread to two and a half people
so if you stop it and there's still
virus it will keep going and grow up
again so we have to be clear on that
my gut is I mean obviously science will
win and the data will win and I think my
hope what the president is saying is
let's see data every day and see where
we are and then make a decision based on
the data let's not say in advance that
it's gonna be X number of weeks and that
I buy into the key thing here really is
to see what's going on and so what we're
gonna see is the end of this week we're
gonna see the impact of what we all have
done the last week which is draconian
measures we all have played a part and
stepped back and hopefully dramatically
stop the spread of the virus he says
let's not let the Cure be worse than the
problem does that make sense to you
again I'm not an economist but what I do
know is the economy won't do well if the
virus keeps going and so I think you
have to look at on both sides is so if
you open the economy and the virus keeps
going we're gonna be in a worse
situation than we are in now you should
say the most businesses probably are not
likely to reopen if there is still a
health crisis but I wanted to ask you
how will we know when it is safe to
loosen these restrictions so we need to
see the stop the spread of the virus I
mean so community spread which is
person-to-person spread has to go down
dramatically in order to loosen the
restrictions it's a numbers game and at
the same time if we start to have
treatments so let's say we do find
somebody with a virus and we can
actually give them a drug that we know
works we can actually stop the spread
from him to somebody else or her to to
other people doctor the president raised
the spectre of suicides if the economy
as badly some economists think it will
there is a term for that in the in the
literature deaths of despair is it
legitimate to calculate those sort of
fatalities against the fatalities that
come with the virus itself of course you
have to look at the whole picture right
we are an enterprise and so you cannot
just say you know we're gonna put
everyone in their house forget the
economy forget jobs or we're gonna have
social disruption we're gonna have young
people start to go into the streets and
say I've got no income I can't survive
and so it needs to be a hybrid of those
and you know as we get more and more
science and data we can figure out
exactly what to do so as we think about
potentially opening up sectors of the
economy or portions of the country one
one idea raised by the president is that
certain parts of the country less
hard-hit could come back sooner
economically is that a legitimate
approach than I think we can open
certain parts of the country potentially
although I'm not sure that's gonna be
likely but the other side is people
who've been exposed that has antibodies
to the virus and it's safe for them to
go out they can be an upstart part of
the economy we can actually
differentiate elderly haven't been
exposed if you have been exposed you can
go out wait David before you go doctor
foul she wasn't at the press conference
yesterday a lot of people find his
presence very reassuring was that a
surprise to you that he wasn't there I
know you've talked to the White House
about different things were you reading
too much into it yeah I think you know
listen I think I hope is they wanted
social distance they have a small number
of people you can't have a panel of 10
people speaking at every conference he's
a reassuring voice and he's real science
and we all believe in them all right
David thank you